one of the moments in the film that
really stood out to become like a great
meme online is Luke brushing the dirt
off of his shoulder elation fighting
kylo Ren was that improvised how did you
come to that moment I know I I think
that was scripted
I do remember doing it once where I did
brush brush yeah which sort of mirrored
the Barack Obama yes but as Ryan said he
goes twice as overkill just one supreme
leader don't get distracted I'll go
right away said now I think one of the
things that the fans are gonna be so
excited to see in the blu-ray Exorcist a
documentary behind the scenes getting to
see everything when you watched it did
you get emotional seeing yourself with
Frank and with carry on yes of course I
can't find something Scott
no one's ever really gone
I asked Anthony how much footage do you
have 1800 hours and it's it's different
than most occu memories because most
documentaries they'll show up clip from
the film and then they'll be talking
heads and you'll see a long shot of that
non-set you know they wired up all the
crew they have it's the closest to it's
like being a fly on the wall as they're
making this blockbuster of course in
Star Wars the last Jedi we all remember
the scenes of Luke teaching Rey on his
self-exiled
island in the blu-ray extras we get a
glimpse into that journey and where it
all happened
Ireland yes that stunning Island was no
CGI
it's called skellig michael even though
I think I know it all they throw things
have me story-wise I never could have
imagined I got a chance to check it all
out while celebrating marks home away
from home
during the st. Patty's Day Parade
[Music]
and saw him speak as the international
guest of honor during the creative minds
series gala in Dublin now next up for
mark will a Jedi become a guardian
people got really excited when you
talked to James Gunn about guardians of
the galaxy 3 are you talking forget the
kid you going over to his house and
bring some tea and chat about it well it
happened organically somebody said hey
James gonna put Mark Hamill and Galaxy
the gardens of galaxy 3 and he wrote
back well he was around the corner maybe
we'll have coffee and talk about it and
so I immediately responded more than
willing to come and I do love the
guardians of galaxy film but they don't
need me that they've got such a talented
cast